تحدث معه حول إدارة صورة
ماسالا ، كل شخص يريد
أن يرتبط بلاعب يؤدي على هذا
المستوى وعندما يكون لديه الكاريزما التي
يتمتع بها عندما يكون محبوبًا جدًا وما
لاحظته عنه
أنه محبط جدًا  على الأرض ، إنه سهل
الوصول إليه لدرجة أنه لوحظ أيضًا
في سوق حقوق الصورة
وفي تلك الصناعات يعرفون
أنه ليس مغنية صفرية سلوك مغني
بسيط للغاية عملي للغاية وهذا ما يمكنني
قوله في هذا المستوى من كرة
القدم  نادرًا ما سألته عما إذا
كان سيرى عقده في
ليفربول ، فمن الواضح أن السؤال الذي
يريد الجميع أن يسأله أنت محاميه ،
ما هو الجواب على هذا السؤال لماذا
سأخبرك الآن هو أن محمد
سعيد جدًا في ليفربول إنه رائع جدًا.  سعيد
لأنه يشعر أنه قضى أفضل
أوقاته في النادي ،
لذا فهو يركز
بنسبة 100٪ في الوقت الحالي على ليفربول وعلى الفوز
بالألقاب مع الكبد ، هل تتوقع
أن تتلقى مكالمات بشأنه من الأندية الأخرى.
أنت تأخذ هذه الأهداف ، بالتأكيد
أعني أنها شيء يعني أنني
سأُطرح هذا السؤال وإجابتي على
ذلك لن يكون الأمر غريبًا إذا
لم يحدث ذلك لأنه إذا كان لديك أندية كبرى
ولديك ما أعنيه
محمد.  من الواضح أنه أفضل لاعب
في إنجلترا في الوقت الحالي ، لذا
ألن يكون الأمر غريبًا إذا لم تكن تلك الأندية الضخمة
تتصل بالسؤال بالطبع ، فهم
جوابي على ذلك ، نعم بالتأكيد هناك
محمد هو بالتأكيد أهم
الأصول في السوق اليوم  حصلت على واحدة
أعلم أنه أخذ
نصيحتك قبل عامين وجعله
يشارك فيها وهو مبادرة مخدرات لماذا
عندما يرى شاب نموذجًا يحتذى
به مرتبطًا بمبادرة من أجل
مكافحة إدمان المخدرات ، أعتقد أنه
قد يفكر مرتين قبل الذهاب  في هذا
المسار وفي نفس الوقت إذا كنت
بالفعل في مشكلة إذا كنت مدمنًا بالفعل
وترى أن هناك
شخصًا على مستوى محمد يطلب
منك أن تنظر ، اتصل بهذا الرقم وسوف
يساعدك بشكل فعال  وها  فوائد S
تماما في آخر واحد قام في
الأساس
بإصدار الإعلان في يوم واحد وفي اليوم التالي زيادة
المكالمات إلى خط المساعدة بنسبة 400٪